bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france mouvements de
grèves et manifestations organisée ce
lundi quelle est la situation a en ce
moment même sur l'île
et colleter actuellement nous avons donc
plusieurs centrales syndicales qui
appellent à la grève générale il y a eu
des défilés dans les rues de fort de
france et il y a plusieurs points des
zones commerciales qui sont bloqués
pour ceux qui connaissent la zone de la
lézarde les mangues jambette il y à des
points d'accès à la rs le point fort de
france donc voila un petit peu la
situation aujourd'hui quel est le lien
qu'il existe entre le mouvement de
protestation en martinique et celui qui
se joue depuis plusieurs jours en
guadeloupe
ben c'est le même lien il faut dire que
ce qui arrive le feu aux poudres a été
la déclaration de macron le 2 juillet
par dans d'obligations maximale et
surtout les sanctions c'est à dire
suspension de salaire de contrat de
travail
de toute allocation de tous revenus ça
c'était une véritable déclaration de
guerre en fait au mois de mars il avait
dit on faisait la guerre où le virus
mais la déclaration de guerre aux
travailleurs
et ça ça ne passe pas du tout et avec
l'envoi et 102
d'unités d'élite de la police et de la
gendarmerie pour lutter on pour
impressionner les populations ici en lui
la salle d'eau qui a fait déborder rue
basse était vraiment de de l'huile que
le gouvernement a versé sous le feu vous
revendiquez sur marc knicks ont varié
vous l'avez évoqué il ya à la fin de
l'obligation vaccinale et des
suspensions pour les soignants est aussi
une demande de hausse des salaires et
des minima sociaux une baisse des prix
des carburants et du gaz ont réclamé
aussi la prise en charge totale des
tests de chlore d'économies est ce qu'on
peut parler d'un mouvement de colère
générale et de défiance aussi vis-à-vis
de l'état
plus qu'un mouvement de défiance
vis-à-vis de l'état vous savez le d'état
allemand à la population de ce pays
depuis déjà des années et la seule
réponse que l'état trouve à portée
lorsqu'il y aller lui c'est tout
simplement la répression on l'a vu le 18
octobre on l'a vu le 15 octobre sur le
site de l'hôpital de la mi temps lorsque
on a eu des gendarmes mobiles et des
policiers qui sont venus tabasser
menotté gaz et des travailleurs
ça c'est la seule réponse de l'état oui
c'est vrai nous avons un contentieux il
ya la question de la chlordécone qui qui
traîne depuis déjà de nombreuses années
il ya des augmentations de salaires que
nous demandons il y à aussi
mais pas seulement la question des de
l'obligation vaccinale il ya aussi la
question de des réformes entamées par le
gouvernement notamment les régimes de
retraite peut pas parler de réformes et
de démantèlement ainsi que des nouvelles
dispositions concernant l'indemnisation
des chômeurs ce sont toutes ces raisons
qui nous conduisent aujourd'hui à
appeler l'ensemble du monde du travail à
à se mettre en grève ou exiger du
gouvernement qui nous donne les moyens
effectivement dans ce pays emmanuel
macron c'est d'exprimer ce matin au
sujet de la situation en guadeloupe il a
notamment dénoncé je cite la
manipulation par certains de cette
situation qu'est ce que vous répondez
aux accusations selon lesquelles cette
crise sanitaire serait récupérée à des
fins politiques
alors je demande à monsieur emmanuel
macron d'aller balayer devant sa porte
d'abord parce que c'est lui qui à de
nombreuses reprises a déclaré qu'il n'y
aurait pas d' obligation vaccinale je
peux lui donner des dates le vent 2020
décembre 2020 mai 2021 donc il commence
déjà par balayer devant sa porte
monsieur m on y attend et il a décidé
pour des raisons qu'il ne veut pas
avouer de passer à une autre phase nous
nous disons tout simplement que il
s'agit pas d'une minorité il s'agit de
grès problème de rayer malaise dans la
population et nous allons plus loin que
ça nous demandons parce que nous sommes
certains que de nombreux travailleurs de
france partagent les mêmes
préoccupations que nous notamment sur la
question des salaires nous sur la
question des patients des wattret et
d'autres questions nous nous adressons
directement travailleurs de france en
leur disant de
dix ans que nous sommes des frères dans
ce combat et comme les appelons à nous
rejoindre dans ce combat parce que c'est
vrai que depuis des années nous endurons
des choses ici de manière plus
importante qu'en france mais nous sommes
sur les mêmes préoccupations
et vous ne vous sentez pas représentés
par les élus locaux sur l'île
écoutez les élus locaux ils sont en
train de quatre meilleurs quatre députés
de sénateurs on ne les entend pas donc
sur une île 2005 km² je veux quand même
crois que il devrait savoir ce qui se
passe si l'on décidé de garder leurs
distances il ya bien une raison
d'ailleurs ça nous amène à dire que nous
travaillons nous devons nous occuper de
lui oppose à faire nous mêmes et ne pas
compter sur eux merci d'avoir pris le
temps de réagir sur notre antenne d'un
gabriel jean marie javel que cette
secrétaire général de la cgt martinique